如果你是在那种不正规的金融借贷平台借钱，
比如说借5万，
他给你打4万，
在这种情况下的话，
我建议你摆烂，
因为他这种做法是违法的，
不可以这么搞的，
摆烂到最后的话，
可以协商，
比如说协商我就还本钱，
你实际借我多少，
我还多少，
我给你一定的法定的利息，
法定的利息，
法律支持的利息可能就是年息十几，
我26岁，
我老公33岁，
我们文凭都是个大专，
今婚四年，
有一个小孩，
三岁多，
我是一个经济上面的问题，
我很迷茫，
我老公从结婚前跟我结婚，
买房买车，
这些可能借了一点钱嘛，
就相当于他是负债的情况，
在结婚这四年，
他前面三年工作都不是很稳定，
都是相当于干半年休半年的情况嘛，
房子有房贷，
是我们领结婚证之前两个人一起贷款的，
是他还房贷，
但是目前因为房子的问题，
他那个房子质量的问题，
我们一直没去收房，
所以是延期还款的，
一直在延期还款。
两年了，
房贷一个月是2400，
车子的今年我们8月份刚换的我的名字，
我来还贷款，
每个月贷款是2600，
还三年。
结婚前三年，
我们一家三口是在一个超一线城市工作生活，
那个时候。
我在一个民营医院上班，
上班了两年，
因为工资不是很高，
我就辞职了，
换了一个销售岗，
干了一年，
每个月大概在一万四五，
这个工资就是勉强维持了家庭的开支吧，
因为我们在大城市消费比较高，
而且我自己对钱不是很敏感，
所以一直存不下钱，
可能家庭遇到的一些其他的特殊意外情况，
我就只能交晚贷，
总共结婚四年下来，
我一共是七八十八万的完贷，
我老公的话，
他不是前面三年工作基本上都是干半年收到姆嘛，
所以家庭的开支都是我在承担，
他赚的工资他也基本上都是还他之前结婚请的债吧，
但是也没有还多少，
他都是雪球样，
越滚越大，
两一清，
他姐姐就给了他一笔，
前16万给他全部还清了。
近一年我老公他因为备考那个医学证书就没有上班了啊，
我们就回到了我们现在买房的四线城市，
目前的话我是在我亲戚的店里面上班，
每个月到手是6000块钱到8万，
也没有五险，
他这几年都没有上班，
还好的是他现在已经考过了，
考过了他现在在准备考他们当地的编制和进医院了，
近两年吧，
因为他也没有什么工。
做他的消费基本上都是靠信用卡和每个月我借济他几千块钱，
大概他的债务就是信用卡七八万块钱吧，
也是逾期的状态。
我自己目前就是拆东墙补西产，
也比较煎熬，
我亏了我老公，
他不知道我欠了网贷，
他以为我之前做销售存了一些钱，
其中这个网贷大头资就是因为前年我哥结婚，
我借了5万块钱给他，
其实我也没钱，
我就是直接在找了一个金融机构贷的款，
也不懂什么手续费和利息，
本来说好贷5万，
结果只下来了4万，
结果利息一起交，
我还将近8万块钱，
反正被骗了也不敢跟任何人说，
我就在想我下一步是怎么怎么，
那你哥还你钱了吗？
问你哥借钱啊，
我借了我哥5万块钱，
他已经还了我2万了，
他还欠我3万块钱，
如果你是在那种不正规的金融借贷平台借钱，
比如说借5万，
他给你打4万，
在这种情况下的话，
我建议你摆烂，
因为他这种做法是违法的，
不可以这么搞的，
摆烂到最后的话，
可以协商，
比如说协商我就还本钱，
你实际借我多少，
我还多少，
我给你一定的法定的利息，
法定的利息，
法律支持的利息可能就是年息十几，
好，
你还有啥问题要问我呢？
我在想，
如果这个钱的话，
很多人他说我为什么要借钱给我哥。
我读大学的学费和生活费都是我哥出的，
所以我哥说困难的时候你也支持他吗？
还有什么问题要问我呢？
我在想，
如果我这样的我师后应该怎么做呀？
网贷全部逾期慢慢还对吗？
是这样啊，
网贷逾期了之后，
比如说他去起诉你或者干嘛的，
真到那一步了还可以协商，
比如说我还本金多少，
利息给我减多少是可以协商的，
大不了就这样吗？
知道吧，
以后就是量入为初了，
所以说只是我自己的开销，
说实话，
我的工资啊，
我赚的钱都是完全的覆盖的，
但是我总感觉我老公一直在拖我的后腿，
你老公现在不是考上了什么资格了吗？
那就等他找工作了，
那找工作了之后，
现在你就得把这个经济抓起来呀，
而且你要明确的跟他说呀，
呃，
当初我这个网贷是什么情况下，
我确实没办法了，
我撸了网贷呀，
我养孩子啊，
得花钱呀，
没办法呀，
对的，
我觉得你哥那个事儿得尽快解决，
尽快解决是什么意思呢？
得尽快把你这个钱还了，
你这话说破天了，
作为一个丈夫听到的话都会心里不舒服的，
你本身没有你去借网贷去给你哥结婚这事儿是你做的不对，
对，
就你老公的话，
他是有权利发脾气的。
是的，
其实我一直就在想，
其实大不了说完还蛋去，
没逾期跟我老公坦白很好。
沟通，
但是我一直下不了这个决心，
不知道为什么，
总是想一扛再扛，
前面两天我跟我老公吵架，
我就梳理了一下，
这一年我跟我老公，
我就转了他6万块钱，
而且他自己的工资反正也没花在我们身上，
你这事不能扛吗？
我自己扛，
我怕你到时候扛不住了之后心里就崩溃了，
现在才十几万，
也两个人扛一扛，
让你哥再还点钱也还好，
对，
其实我也是这么想的，
别的没啥了哈，
好，
就这样啊，
拜拜。
其实我某种程度上我也理解刚才这个姑娘，
我原来也有个这个阶段，
打肿脸充胖子了，
总觉得自己想要挑大梁，
总觉得因为我我这一路读书啊，
全家人勒紧裤腰带，
爸爸妈妈都不消费，
哥哥挣了点钱也贴补给我了，
我年轻的时候也有过这个阶段，
就想要挑大梁，
就想让我工作了，
我挣钱了，
我一个人撑起一个家，
我一个人要让你们都过好日子，
也有过那种打肿脸充胖子的阶段，
也有个贷款给他们去做这个做那个的阶段，
但我现在回过头来想的话，
其实那么做做是不对的，
某种程度上你会为大亲人的心理预期，
会为大他们的这个欲望，
我不知道有多少人能明白我说的这个，
就像你，
你哥问你借5万块钱，
你自己去贷款借给他，
他不了解你的情况，
他以为你多有钱似的，
他也。
给你，
你本来能给我借8万，
但你只借我5万，
他以为你多有钱似的，
但是这个姑娘呢，
现在好在第一还不是完全的负向资产，
因为好在还是有房有车的嘛，
好在是贷款额度还不是很大，
十几万就是悬崖勒马，
还能够翻转头来，
还能够有自己的翻盘的机会。
鸿飞姐姐年轻的时候也贷过款嘛，
也有啊，
那种消费贷我有，
我是民生银行的消费贷的，
有30万的额度呢，
我年轻的时候，
我现在我基本上我就不贷款了，
我买房子我也不贷款，
我买车我也不贷款，
我不贷款，
我现在就不想背债，
不想背贷款过日子，
就有多大能力咱就买多大车，
有多大能力我就买多大房子，
我不贷款，
我现在是这样的生活方式，
记得点赞关注哦。